no and someone on the phone says Trump's
being a disaster on purpose it's banning
strategy no no it isn't he didn't say
the Trump comb out and make a fool
yourself and Trump went great yeah so
it's incorrect people in Washington may
have bait they're calculating but they
don't think like that
they're people plus he's a guy with the
biggest ego in the world he's gonna go
get bad publicity I'm perfect I'll make
a fool out of yourself okay no problem
Steve you're in charge good point Steve
yeah should connect should I go make fun
of Arnold Schwarzenegger - yep that's my
idea you're standing at all your your
Energy's up I'm leaning I'm leaning
against [ __ ] I can't come trying to lean
comfortably and I can't it's against the
wall
you figured out your spatial relations
over there yet but I'm leaning against
the wall and I'm really comfy good good
damage can make the wheels so yeah I
mean that's that's uh that's a look into
and left if I fell oh my god it's the I
I thought I thought that Trump doing
this press conference yesterday was the
best thing I would see all week if you
fell it would have been better than the
press conference you've been happy oh uh
uh her the doll thought of my head
hitting the counter oh and I hold my
coffee oh that would be great and then I
would remember that we video everything
yep we would have it on YouTube like
before the end of the show before the
commercial break and we're gonna break
it like five minutes before the
commercial break we would have it up
stop looking at the camera I may I may
just fall
put a video up of you stumbling on the
charity no don't don't because it made
me look foolish yeah maybe
actually it's dizzle in there it's
discipline no no no don't put it up
because people gonna last anything I'm a
fool he's eating breakfast hey daesil
can you both breath kiss this cuter can
we do like breakfast
can you like an animated gif yeah from
that video no no it's gonna make me look
stupid and clumsy he wants you to do an
animated gif of Jim almost falling just
don't make me look stupid time yeah but
I gotta look cool it was at the end of
this first hour it just happened make em
look cool pipe hat on them yeah I gotta
look like cool as [ __ ] make a note of
the time and let's just get across
social media a little gif of Jim
stumbling on
chair that sounds good right happened
about 8:05 yeah it's gonna be cool
though it didn't happen at 8:05 it's
gonna look cool you know think people
are gonna mock me I know no no no we're
gonna make sure it looks cool yeah deep
they just said make it look cool though
I said yeah make it look cool
yeah yeah it'll be good don't let Jim
forget that he's end